ja wir machen das jetzt so du wartest
wieder teleportieren wir uns okay oder
laufenden halten
da hin ich hab keinen bock das jetzt
auch wichtig um zu stellen weil wir
dafür den kompletten server neu starten
müssten alter ach du scheiße gar nicht
so schwer aus das kann man sogar ohne
sprint machen zwar schon das dorf bist
ja wie weit ich bin du musst in der in
immer in der luft teilweise wieder nach
hinten drücken damit er ein bisschen fad
abnimmt
ich bin abgerutscht
das hat sofort von cotta cloud macht ihr
das weiß ich nicht ich hab das gar von
dir formate geklaut sogar ich bekomme du
hast nicht was zu trinken
dass mehr geht es mir
er hat kann nicht sein
doch kann sein das headset hat ein
langes kabel alte an schaltet sich die
einfach das mac punkt als ausleihe das
war ähnlich heiß weil du musstest du
wieder nach hause fahren
ja sieht man neben mich alter wie es mit
dem bus wieder zurück gewinnen wo sein
opfer
ich dachte du weißt wie ritter schlagen
wollte ich auch okay gute suppe oder so
bestimmen warte auf meinen schatz die
nehmen das teilweise viel zu ernst was
die leute auf youtube da musst du den
sagen die soll es mehr die teilnehmen
der täter werde etat wurde bist so gut
ich war vorhin so weit
ja was soll ich denn sagen ich bin fast
durch gewesen martin und ich habe das
ganze ein ganz tolles tutorial in
minecraft angesehen
sag mal was das tutorial macht tutorial
wie geht man in minecraft dann zeigt mir
dass man wer ist die drückende gedacht
die auch das muss ich euch bitte nochmal
zeigen
da war so kommt caruso von wenn ja das
ist ein weg das geht gar nicht
man kann ich laufen ich war so nah dran
ich hab den ja wort erfolg schon
gerochen
man ist ein bisschen nervig mit dem
portal dauert so lange weil theoretisch
wartet bis doch mal bescheid
nimm dein bett nämlich mit uns schnell
dass da unten neben mainz dann legen wir
uns nochmal penan beim never explodieren
die betten tochter jenny nein ich mache
hier dauert das heißt auch folge brachte
jetzt ein bisschen kleinerer weg
deswegen unnötig deswegen und richtig
leid ich will dich zurück
wir können uns da wenn wir jetzt in fünf
minuten immer noch nicht geschafft haben
einfach ein creative machen darüber
später können wir wieder hoch fliegen du
wurdest du steckst mich normalen welt
bleibt da drin machst
ich will mir hey ich hab grad creative
und so ich hab gehört den fünf minuten
und so das ist aber schon 10 uhr oha
damit nicht klappen
also zehn uhr morgens natürlich nein ich
analysiere das gleich erstmal ich
analysiere dieses level wie weit es geht
so schauen wir uns das jetzt an spielen
dahinten dass sie das war ja gar nicht
wissen wann die kommt an martin ist
nicht witzig und kreativ malta wir beim
springen die challenger nicht sondern
wir machen uns das nur ein bisschen
einfacher
1 nachher ein scheiße kontrast game
world konkrete ohne witz jetzt schaffe
ich es gerade jetzt machen wie weit ich
schon bin
ach du scheiße wieder hoch motiviert
oder gefallen erklärte jetzt geht nicht
auf den zaun drauf ich kann das gar
nicht ich bin würde ich die map allein
gespielt
ich glaube ich bräuchte gut fünf stunden
für diese challenge oh doch ich sterbe
gerechnet was da noch gar nichts
geschaffen da ich bin schon hier vorne
dass man keine an jedoch wir haben bei
ungefähr gleich viel geschafft so gott
wo ich bin
ich hab's geschafft ich auch bis
rübergeflogen ich hab doch ihr nachher
den aufnahmen das heißt ich kann es
sehen ein dass kein videobeweis doch
schaufel um schaufel zwei schaufeln
chatten der anti graf aktivist game mode
000 also nicht game mode
du musst du daher musst ja ich glaube
einfach dem laufsport hinterher so ich
habe jetzt eine schaufel und ich habe
auch eine schaufel film jedoch nichts
zwei schaufeln ich hab noch ein level 2
leather ach du scheiße verstehe ich aber
als ohne hallo hier ist noch mit land
abbauen können aber besser jetzt gehen
wir durch katheter hitliste kiste jetzt
auch save your stuff eine schaufel und
zwei kreml ja aber ich habe etwas
wichtigeres gefunden was denn oder da
und anschubsen ach du scheiße ja
deswegen und ich habe jetzt gerade
machen never und weiß nicht wo ich den
hinsetzen soll er vielleicht in die
links mike card aber das ist jetzt schon
weg bin
die muss ich da hinten hinsetzen da
clever das heißt wenn ich drauf gehe
wahrscheinlich hat den rapper da
vielleicht rein tun sollen martin ja wir
machen das jetzt so du wartest wieder an
teleportieren wir uns okay oder laufen
halt immer wieder dahin ich hab
vergessen
aber ich lebe ich lebe
ok wenn quadras mich nicht töten ich
gehe nach oben gamer tpg scheiße
und die schlagen trotzdem dass eltern
warum sprichst weiter ja ich bin jetzt
hier unten
bring your self um oder kannst ja
einfach zu erraten
das ist natürlich jetzt bisschen doof
dass wir die betten hier unten stehen
haben
du kannst du auch einfach dicht
teleportieren erwarte ich meister den
schalter dahin noch ein weiter
gesprungen was ich kann mich doch
einfach jetzt ich werde da händler
was bringt das hinter runter wirst so
dahin nicht doch darunter sehr guten hat
ihn sehr schön sehr schön ja
durchbrochen
ich brauche den schalter warte ich mal
ich weiß wie wir das machen wenn ich
kann mich einfach zu deportieren stimmt
wieso kann ich die wir müssen ja drauf
setzen jetzt mal drauf dann gehe ich
schnell auf die kiste nein egal weil ihr
nicht wichtig ist drin außerdem schaufel
und zwei leben
da war auch leitern drin was bringt es
wenn jetzt wenn wir das jetzt geschafft
vielleicht bräuchte mit leitern und
wieder hochzukommen
aha ich bin schlau ist das denn ptf
deswegen blieb oder wieder
zurückgefahren warte ich guck mal da
kommt es nicht mehr her
ich muss einfach überspringen
stimmt martin ein ziemlich alt im
creative nein da ich hab das gesuchte
teil älter ich würde sagen wir machen in
den vier minuten ganz kurzen stopp
welche wissen muss schon wieder ist da
schon wieder ich war halt noch nicht
also ich war heute schon doch klar
ja ja ja toll ich bin jetzt wieder oben
ach ja stimmt ist es so etwas einfach
umbringen sollen ja ich weiss ich war
jetzt oben aber der internet das bringt
mir nichts
wir brauchen hier den schalter so wir
müssen den schalter drücken oder hast du
den gedrückt ich hab den gedrückt hat
das war gerade dabei hier oben ist jetzt
nichts passiert
13 also 14 das offen nicht das ist
butter wolf klar ein okay du bist platz
zwei alter heizöl zu bekämpfen so da
sind drei knochen das heißt ich sehe mir
neben den hund okay gut ich habe eine
rüstung anziehen
ich hole mir noch mehr ganz ehrlich und
ich kann aber nicht mehr browns aller
weg.de und komm her und coaching in
meiner läuft hinterher dass gutes ja ich
habe 2 ich habe nur ein aha ich hab zwei
kommt mit martin kommt alter hier sind
jetzt erstmal diese komischen spinnen
also das ist jetzt an wellen spiel
wahrscheinlich dass da so verschiedene
wellen kommen oder einfach nur ganz ganz
viele mops hier sind so räume wo so
schalter sind ist offen wer dich jetzt
wieder zu müssen wie die hunde
daransetzt oder wir brauchen alle items
wir brauchen einfach nur items nee das
geht nicht weil es in der presse display
das bei dir ne wurden können darauf
setzen stimmt loskommt beide sitzen
darauf ausgeschafft cool
es war wohl einfach schalter gedrückt
den habe ich schon gedrückt
wir müssen wieder drauf setzen
ich soll ja dass meine das ist eine
gemeine kommen jetzt mit hier und mit
rein mit dem keine ahnung hatte mach so
wirklich
wer mich drauf da stelle ich einfach
drauf eben rüber
viele punkte ich mich an lag den ex
quest und runter auf der karte kann sich
den portieren glaube ich wo willst du
hin immer geschafft
wir müssen aber hier hin ja ich weiß da
noch einmal ein game können wir noch
machen nein schon wieder irgendwas mit
tunneln das ist das los des fds stewart
for you legend of fire resistance nein
ich benutze nur wenn es zu hart für die
sfb games sachs gott du scheiße man muss
immer bei den blues sound entstehen dann
wurde einfach die ganze töpfen dann
passierte gar nichts
ich hab's geschafft
okay ich bin jetzt im wasser dahinten
das lawa aber martin ja ich bin auch
hier aber hinten dilaver die mache ich
schon mitfeiern resistance level eine
wolfsburg etwas abgeben kann
geil steht noch